[Music]
this summer I jumped off a bridge
[Music]
probably 65 feet tall
I've jumped off it probably a dozen
times in my life mostly when I was a
teenager but this time I kind of started
to drift a little bit back and when they
hit the water I felt like pain my entire
back and then I couldn't walk for a
little bit yeah it's pretty bad so I
probably won't jump off that bridge
again but it was fine this summer while
I was working on boarders India I went
back west to where I grew up and while I
was there on this trip I thought a lot
about a question I get often which is
what is it like to have a job and a
lifestyle where you're constantly moving
around and in foreign places and I think
I'm starting to develop an answer to
that question so let me tell you the
story of the summer and maybe share with
you some of the reflections I've had
while I was on the road
[Music]
so I first started in Utah we did what
you should do if you go to Utah which is
spend time in the mountains we also went
to the south of the state where we
explore Zion National Park and went on
one of the most beautiful hikes I've
ever been on in my life then we went up
to Park City which is like an hour from
Salt Lake and participated in their town
wide dinner that they have they shut
down Main Street they put a bunch of
tables out and you can sit there on this
giant communal table and eat dinner with
a bunch of random people which was kind
of fun and amazing and Park City in the
summer is kind of a dream this whole
time I was spending 12-hour days in a
coffee shop working on borders India the
writing the editing the animation and it
was this kind of crazy moment of intense
days and then during the night having
some like very concentrated family time
[Music]
from there I went down to Reno Nevada
where I spent a weekend with some of my
buddies from college linked oh is this
very cold but very beautiful lake in
California and Nevada and it was such a
great time catching up with these people
who I went to call it with and - I
haven't really seen in a lot of years
[Music]
from there I flew home to Oregon
[Music]
[Music]
Ashland Oregon which is the town I was
born in and where I spent the first 19
years of my life
[Music]
our hands have since moved away from
that town and none of my siblings live
there and it was my first time back in
in a lot of years and it kind of blew my
mind
[Music]
blew my mind to be in this place that I
hadn't been in years this place I had
grown up in and take it for granted and
suddenly felt like I was seen it from a
totally new perspective from an
outsider's perspective and I realized
like wow this place is beautiful
a strange feeling when you experience
something that is incredibly familiar
but you have enough distance from it in
terms of how much time it's been since
you've been there that it also feels
novel so it's like you're experiencing
it for the first time from a new
perspective but it's also incredibly
familiar that is the weirdest feeling of
nostalgia meets novelty and it's intense
it's like an intense feeling and that's
exactly what I was feeling the entire
time I was in Ashland
[Music]
[Music]
- Linda's mainly stayed the same but
since I lived there I've changed
completely and I've seen the world
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
from there we drove to one of the most
special parts of the world from you
which is the Oregon coast
Oregon has this big rugged coastline on
the Pacific Ocean and it just feels so
abundant and open
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm telling you all this for a reason
which is the answer this question of
what is it like to have a life when you
are constantly in foreign places and
experiencing new things the summer I
filled my tank with these familiar
connections being out in nature in
familiar landscape with people that I've
known for decades and connecting with
places that have a lot of meaning for me
that was really quieting for my soul
this was a really necessary
counterbalance to what had been a year
of non-stop going to other unfamiliar
places what this means is as my little
family grows and as I think about my
career growing as I think about things
like borders and this channel and this
company we're launching in in December I
am going to be thinking about the best
most intentional way to make travel a
life-giving and like positive experience
it was a good summer
overall borders published and I got to
be in these beautiful familiar places
and you can't really ask for more than
that
I want to thank
Skillshare for sponsoring this video
I've talked about Skillshare a lot
before because I believe in skill share
and love skill share and believe in the
ethos of the brand and the mission of
the company skill share if you don't
know what it is is a online learning
platform where you can browse like
thousands and thousands of different
tutorials that are really high quality
and really approachable everything from
design to video to photography to coding
to animation like all you can learn
whatever you want there's one course in
particular that I really like on
Skillshare it's called animation for
graphic designers which is a really
helpful course for learning really
elegant ways to move shapes and text to
make flat 2d logos or other text
elements come to life the cool thing is
you can subscribe to Skillshare and for
a monthly fee and you get unlimited
access to all of this stuff if you
subscribe to the annual subscription
it's less than ten bucks a month because
they're sponsoring this video you can
sign up with my specific link and get
two months of this for free so you can
try it out and see if it's useful for
what you are interested in learning in
your day to day life
Thank You Skillshare for sponsoring this
video thanks for watching I will be back
with another video soon I actually have
a really fun video lined up that has to
do with explaining why Amsterdam has ten
holes so take a look out for that all
right have a great day
[Music]